Hey, hey, you, you I don't like your girlfriend No way, no
way I think you need a new one Hey, hey, you, you I could be
your girlfriend Hey, hey, you, you I know that you like me
No way, no way No, it's our secret Hey, hey, you, you I want
to be your girlfriend You're so fine, I want your mind,
you're so delicious I think about you all the time, you're
so addicted Don't you know what I can do to make you feel
alright?
Don't pretend I think you know I'm damn precious And hell
yeah, I'm the motherfucking princess I can tell you like me
too, and you know I'm right She's like, so whatever You
could do so much better I think we should get together now
And that's what everyone's talking about I don't like your
girlfriend No way, no way I think you need a new one Hey,
hey, you I could be your girlfriend Hey, hey, you, you I
know that you like me No way, no way No, it's our secret
Hey, hey, you, you I want to be your girlfriend I can see
the way I see the way you look at me And even when you look
away I know you think of me I know you talk about me All the
time again and again So come over here and tell me what I
wanna hear Better yet, may your girlfriend disappear I don't
wanna hear you say your name ever again And again and again
and again Cause she's like, so whatever You could do so much
better I think we should get together now And that's what
everyone's talking about Hey, hey, you, you No way, no way I
think you need a new one Hey, hey, new you I could be a
girlfriend Hey, hey, new you I know that you like me No way,
no way No, it's our secret Hey, hey, new you I want to be a
girlfriend In the second you'll be wrapped around my finger
Cause I can, cause I can do it better There's no other, so
when's it gonna sink in?
She's so stupid, what the hell were you thinking?
In the second you'll be wrapped around my finger Cause I
can, cause I can do it better There's no other, so when's it
gonna sink in?
She's so stupid, what the hell were you thinking?
Hey, hey you, you I don't like your girlfriend No way, no
way I think you need a new one Hey, hey, you I could be your
girlfriend Hey, hey, you, you I know that you like me No
way, no it's not a secret Hey, hey, new you I want to be a
girlfriend Hey, hey, new you I don't like your girlfriend No
way, no way I think you need a new one Hey, hey, new you I
could be a girlfriend Hey, hey, new you I know that you like
me No way, no way No, it's not a secret Hey, hey, new you I
want to be a girlfriend Hey, hey, hey!